everyone's favorite American that's
Tiffany's opinion right there I like
your look today thank you
bit of a classy girl and then a little
bit of hit Bob on a car
stupid
got bangers and mash I think I'm getting
that they even hit the occasion ever
arise would you ever like Gordon Ramsay
come into your home and yell at you for
how bad cook follow the misfit like this
you
are you gonna be drinking for this meal
her friends are gonna
or at a fresh up in Vegas let's cut down
to what you have here what is it
Mirabelli exactly you need to calm
yourself after Vegas I'm gonna comment
of course it's always that for something
I will get my beach body back
Thanksgiving for now
want a drink tour days okay have fun
maybe we're in Vegas right
bread it
my bacon burgers patty was already busy
the only five burgers is the fact that
no matter what the price is on the
burger is still just a burger it's the
one food that you really can excel any
further than what it is so I'm trying to
be as British second this morning one of
these
onions mayor's British playing for
sausage green a savings no I
like this you're like I don't want to
eat it maybe if I make something looks
like this it's obvious
and it to you though it looks like [ __ ]
it look like [ __ ] like [ __ ]
enjoy I will murder around to a poo talk
[ __ ] right now
what use compliment her on her shot
you're on my team that's three though
there's a really gigantic first villain
you'll barely see it right there I'm
pretty I guess you go into little pods
with groups of people you could be the
entire love Vegas trip David is really
really nervous I convinced them to get
on I told them look David it's a little
plod you're protected we're not gonna be
more yourself he's like so I won't be
done by myself all right I'm down
funny right now [ __ ] it dude wotcha
oh yeah do I
safety at least look at Davis freaking
out
come on you got it so where the future
looks like a future taxi right here what
if this was unfair a little bit actual
form of transportation that takes around
the city
boy b-boy
whoo
I'm not scared of fighting people I'm
not scared of confrontation but if you
put me near Heights I turn into this it
does to have the motherly touch you'll
adopt another child Jan money to my son
some sleepless now bridges compliment
you or your eyebrows
I can't get it then you want to be your
eyebrows built into your eyes yeah why
did you do it
what are we about to do we're about to
watch watching that
Ches did that for a group of mainly
majority Asians the hotel we stay at is
a generational
the only non Asian thing we've done is
heat at Gordon Ramsay true point on it I
think it's about us is for Asian me and
Joh and now we've been validated to the
slow transition you already been to
Japan girl I mean that's I don't like
that but at least here - oh yeah I like
your costume - I don't know I was
wearing a costume
Thanks finish it was so greatly special
that's
we'll see with the knife
what just happened okay gosh charades
wait wait my mine I'm not on your team
so I think I wanna Verta teams you get
nine points
you know I guess no more do it do it we
scream to look at us can just scream
just let it out
no but not a girl you want like a like a
mad one like ah like a Oh like you doing
there for you walking so fast cuz she's
hungry I don't know hold hot or a what
is this egg tart I like it when you
speak Chinese
hi I was trying to say oh boy boy don't
say
like that is open
kind of embarrassing
like twig